indien hat ein problem mit
drogensüchtigen genauer mit
drogensüchtigen papageien die tiere
lieben die im moment halten opiate da
sind noch viele codein und eliane im
zentralindischen distrikt nemos klünder
die papageien immer öfter die felder und
scheint nicht mehr aufzuhalten zu sein
moment drogensüchtige tiere und davon
gibt es eine menge die top 7 junkies in
der tierwelt jetzt bei pixum seiten
fiction herzlich willkommen ja es gibt
tatsächlich drogenkonsum bei tieren oder
sind nicht haustiere denen zur
allgemeinen belustigung alkohol ins
futter gemischt wird
in der freien natur haben zahlreichen
tierarten herausgefunden wie sie sich in
einen rausch zustand versetzen und wie
erfindungsreich die dabei sind ist
ziemlich verblüffend ich hab da mal
alles zusammengetragen was zu finden ist
und das ist ziemlich spektakulär auf der
wie delfine haben den kugelfisch als
joint für sich entdeckt die bürgern so
lange hin und her wie für in panik gerät
oder zumindest so viel angst dass er das
nervengift rodo toxin ausstößt in
größeren mengen ist es extrem giftig
aber in kleineren dosen brauste die
delfine lassen den kugelfisch an wie
einen joint rund gehen so dass jeder
etwas davon hat voraus treiben wie dann
regungslos unter der wasseroberfläche
und erfreuen sich am eigenen spiegelbild
die sechs auch die schrumpfende hat sich
auf das nervengift botox ihn speziell an
kugel füße kommt er allerdings nicht ran
deshalb gibt ihre lieblingsspeise ein
lift neues der gattung paris durch das
gift wird wie berauscht sehr langsam und
verliert die angst vor fallenden ja
darum macht halt leicht sind fünf in
skandinavien haben sich rentiere auf
pilze spezialisiert wie moodle fliegen
pilze aus dem boden und bekommen
halluzinationen wie bei lsd und je vier
in madagaskar hat sich der riesen
tausendfüßler als drogenlieferant
herausgestellt der [ __ ] magie hat
dafür mit entdeckt dass der
tausendfüßler verspritzt wenn er in
gefahr ist der magie knabbert so lange
am kopf des tieres herum bis es passiert
durch das zenith wird der
tiefenentspannt und ein wenig high und
lässt den riesen 1000
die drei in australien haben dollar bis
eine känguru art den schlafmohn entdeckt
wenn er reif ist und die opiate ihre
wirkung entfalten
machen sie nicht über die mohnfelder her
und berauschen sich allerdings sind sie
nicht so geschickt wie unsere papageien
dazu klaus der zwei auch elefanten haben
wohl eine droge entdeckt wobei hier noch
nicht ganz klar ist wie sie genau
funktioniert die treffen sehr gerne die
früchte des marula baums und torkeln
danach einige zeit durch die steppe
wissenschaftler bezweifeln allerdings
die berauschende wirkung der frucht vor
allem für omas ig tiere wie elefanten
vermutet wird dass das gift einer käfer
puppe die sich oft in der rinde des
baumes einnistet den rausch ausgelöst
und auch der 1 da sind unsere papageien
und die wirklich penetrant ihn so
unfasslich ausgefuchst ja das ist schon
ziemlich und fachlich nicht nur dafür
die felder plündern sie wissen auch
genau wann der richtige zeitpunkt ist so
warten wie bis die bauern die kapseln
angeschnitten haben der was der dann
austritt hat nämlich die größte wirkung
ist es soweit klauen wie die kapseln
regelrechte knabbern die spiele an die
abrechnung siegen dann mit den kapseln
weg wie ein indischer fernsehbericht
zeigt und sie scheinen wirklich abhängig
zu den sechs trommeln oder feuerwerk
kann sie nicht vom opium diebstahl
abhalten kleiner disclaimer opium wird
übrigens legal für schmerzmittel
angebaut ja es ist schon irre und es
gibt nur wenige berichte und forschungen
zum thema lediglich einige studien haben
herausgefunden dass tiere auf jeden fall
ein sehr kurioses thema weniger kurios
als mein plan geht es in der best of
klicks um pläne zu wenn er mal so
richtig ins staunen kommen wollt
empfehle ich bin's watching dieser
playlist hier draufklicken und wenn er
nicht mehr von pixum verpassen wollt
jeder auf krücken also mehr ein abo aufs
auge drücken und nicht vergessen wir
dann auch einen auf die glocke zu geben
bis dann sagt er
[Musik]